oh boy electro gonorrhea you're making
this doctor not know anything don't
believe anything we tell you hidden
among us is a real doctor and it's your
job we will compete in three rounds of
challenges before revealing the truth
can you figure it out
I'm dr. Lamia Johnson and I've been a
pediatrician for 12 years I love being a
pediatrician it's always been my passion
I just loved the bond that I have with
all of my patients hi my name is dr.
Johnson Lee I am a plastic surgeon I've
been in practice for five years I've
always wanted to help people and in
terms of being a plastic surgeon it
really maximizes kind of the technical
ability and also you really make people
happy to see you my name is dr. Becca
baburaj II and I've been a pediatrician
for the past two years I like really
getting involved of the patients and
working with the parents and really
helping them with the the health of
their children one of the challenges of
being a pediatrician I would say is the
paperwork that I have to do it's a lot
and since I'm new I haven't really found
my flow yet I'm dr. David ami ty I have
been working as a doctor of internal
medicine for about 14 years now I've
always had a drive to make a difference
in the world and I feel like medicine
and health care is just a very direct
way to make an impact also really
interested in HIV and AIDS which is part
of internal medicine so I ended up
spending some time working with Doctors
Without Borders okay so for our first
challenge I'm going to get a list of
conditions and I'm going to identify
which are the real ones and which one is
fake all right so we've got groats
disease facial blindness sleeping beauty
syndrome
Jerome I'll sit tight this poisoning
electro gonorrhea alien hand syndrome
and torsonic polarity syndrome groats
disease I'm a huge fan of Curb Your
Enthusiasm that is a made-up disease by
Larry David although you know maybe it's
something that he has I've definitely
heard this one but it's from TV
career enthusiasm so next question
facial blindness this is something that
I don't usually deal with in Pediatrics
but I feel like it's definitely real
there's a lot of different facial
conditions so I'm leaning a little more
towards real sleeping beauty syndrome
I'm pretty sure it is an actual syndrome
or disease I believe it's when somebody
is in the catatonic or kind of like in a
comatose state not too sure it kind of
reminds me of what's that one more
people policy Oh narcolepsy I'm gonna
say sleeping beauty syndrome Israel euro
mastitis poisoning is not a real disease
it sounds like it could have something
to do with the urinary tract but it
doesn't electoral gonorrhea I will tell
you that it's not real it's actually
from a show that I love coffee Futurama
please don't ever diagnose yourself with
this alien hand syndrome this one is
definitely real I've had some patients
with this it has something to do with
the hand and just the the way the hand
functions if I remember correctly it
means that you don't realize that check
the hand is your own so this clearly has
to do with something with your brain's
ability to perceive your environment I
believe if you do have a alien hand
syndrome you're even at risk of possibly
just cutting your arm off or getting rid
of it because you don't think it belongs
on your body torsonic polarity I'm gonna
say that those are those are real words
that have been used in the medical field
I can't tell you that I've heard of it
in that order
it sounds legit it sounds like a real
disorder but I don't know even doctors
aren't sure sometimes sometimes we have
to look things up on Google them
sometimes we don't know all the answers
you know we're here to work together
with you in the second challenge we're
going to play a little game of operation
so I'm gonna see how many pieces I can
get out before I get the buzzer
big game way back into my surgery
rotation I am NOT a surgeon but let's
see how this goes okay I'm gonna try the
easy ones first
so the butterfly in the stomach but this
is making me really nervous okay this
one butterfly I'm gonna be doing the
water on the knee which I'm still not
sure is a real syndrome Oh God water on
the knees out all right let's try the
spareribs and butterflies let's try the
butterflies
[Music]
how about the breadbasket right here we
go okay there's number two there's no
way I'm gonna be able to get some of
these that's just some of these just
looking possible but I'm going to try we
will not do the ankle connected to the
knee bone that's a really long
description for children's game all
right going for number two now the funny
bone sounds like a comedy club success
let's try the writers cramp I'm so
scared I'm gonna do the brain freeze
bone which is supposed to be pretty easy
there we go go for the wishbone you
ganks so I got two and a half let's get
rid of this guy so I can hurt okay yeah
lost on the broken hair Chelsea this is
actually a lot harder than I remember
that's probably why I'm not a surgeon
and also why you don't have three cups
of espresso before you come on this show
haha oh and that's also why I'm not a
surgeon I could talk to a baby that's
what I also don't think it's fair
because I'm towards the end of my
intermittent fasting period so I'm a
little bit hungry and shaky right now
okay that's another one
the wrenched ankle does not look easy
how's this compared to regular
it's exactly the same as regular surgery
I wish we did this during training I'm
gonna try my left hand on this one are
you up I buzzed it that was pretty
terrible that was four I think it's just
cuz I tried to go for the hard one it'll
last two final round Jim you have to
reach way back into med school into my
anatomy and physiology classes and try
to remember some anatomical terms you
know I got a point to where they are on
the body okay
anatomical snuffbox it is right here
it's a little crease here in your hand
kind of in between your thumb and the
base of your thumb your index finger the
ocean is gonna be right here this little
this little mountain ridge thing in
between your lips that's what it is
there's actually a really interesting
story about the philtrum that everybody
has an angel in the womb with them and
when they're born then the angel says
and pushes and it's this little crevice
in the lips right there do I really
believe that maybe not but it's a cuter
but this is the this is the filter right
here
I just Botox on one school Abela to it
today the glabella is the area right in
between the eyebrows it's the muscles I
wonder if my botox is too strong but
when you move your eyebrows together
because you're looking angry and Stern
and you see the two muscles that kind of
meet together and those are the glabella
muscles tragus is the area in the ear
where all high-schoolers really want to
get their ears pierced to really get
into their emo stages I actually want to
get up here soon but I'm a little scared
of how much it's gonna hurt but this is
your Trancas erector pi light it's just
a fancy word for saying goosebumps
they're the tiny tiny little muscles
that are around your hair as well as
yeah mostly just around your hair
follicles so when you get goose bumps
and your hair stands up those are the
muscles that control it now that you've
seen me do all three challenges I'm
pretty sure you know that I am the
doctor it should be pretty obvious that
I'm the doctor I think it's pretty clear
that I'm the real doctor
[Music]
oh boy
did you guys believe me I hope not does
that make you really unhealthy right now
I'm not dr. Rebecca Bieber Audrey I am
comedian
dr. Becca beverage II and honestly
people if I was your doctor I'd be
concerned for you and also do your
research on ZocDoc okay so did I fool
you guys I'm actually not a pediatrician
I am a full-time mother I have four
children I have actually two college
students and two elementary age students
and I've been married over 20 years so I
have my hands full and I not the
pediatrician all right I don't know if I
tricked you guys or not but I am
I have played one on television before I
find that's a lot less stressful I
definitely have a huge respect for what
real doctors actually do so did you guys
get it right turns out I am the actual
doctor and the bit surprised myself but
I did go through all four years of
medical school seven years of surgical
training and I've also been in practice
for five years
as a doctor I am educated and trained in
a wide breadth of medicine as well as
surgery however in my current practice
like to specialize and focus on cosmetic
procedures I do everything from
non-surgical to surgical procedures
Botox fillers breast augmentations
facial surgeries I hope you guys had fun
I am gonna go back to doing some doctor
stuff and I'm actually late for surgery
so I'll see you guys soon
[Music]